foreign
[Music]
for Wednesday February 1st I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
lately Twitter users for you feeds have
been showing a lot of posts from one
men's fashion commentator it's not
because the users all of a sudden care
about streetwear and cowboy Aesthetics
it's got to do with Twitter's algorithm
and recent changes to it so what do
these changes tell us about how owner
Elon Musk is approaching content on the
platform
here now is wsj Twitter reporter Alexa
course hey Alexa thanks for joining us
thanks for having me so can you tell me
about this guy Derek guy and his account
yeah so Derek is a writer in California
and he writes about men's fashion I mean
he gets into like his favorite Italian
tailors how to incorporate a cowboy look
into your wardrobe I mean we are talking
fashion here okay all right and
important things to know it seems like
this man's posts were suddenly
everywhere on Twitter how did he first
realize that this was happening and what
is it meant for you know his follower
count I talked to Derek and he said that
he first realized his posts had gone so
popular when someone tweeted about it
they said why is Twitter trying to make
me follow the menswear guy and he's like
what I had no idea
um that all these people are getting
introduced to my posts I wonder why this
is happening what do we know about it
it's a mystery
um we suspect it has to do with
Twitter's algorithmic timeline which
isn't now known as the for you timeline
tell me a little bit about that is this
something that's new since musk
purchased it does it predate him so
Twitter's had an algorithmic timeline
option for years and basically what it
means is you're not just seeing tweets
from accounts you follow Twitter will
also suggest tweets and things you'll
like even if you're not necessarily
following that account so it's not new
but we know that Elon Musk and Twitter
have been tinkering with the timeline
and increasingly promoting it in recent
weeks he even said that one update
included too many tweets from people
users didn't follow and they were going
to work on fixing that and so the
speculation here is that Derek guy has
somehow been swept up into all the
changes that are happening with the
algorithmic timeline in the last few
weeks how are users reacting to this
tinkering and to seeing maybe people
they consider random like somewhere
talking about menswear Fashion on their
timeline there's been a lot of confusion
and a lot of complaints some users say
they like it better but you know Twitter
has certainly heard a lot of users
complaining and are they reacting to it
I mean he said they're tinkering with it
but have they specifically addressed any
of the complaints well I asked the
company about Derek's account
specifically and they didn't respond to
a request for comment but we know from
Elon himself he tweeted recently that
Twitter staff were in the office past
midnight working on fixing
recommendations you know we talk a lot
about what musk's purchase of Twitter
was going to mean for their content
moderation policy does this tell us
anything about his strategy what we can
expect for him on that front yeah I
think this is a great example of just
the emphasis on speed since musk took
over musk wants to move fast he wants
Twitter to try new things not all those
things are gonna work or go well and
that seems to be what we're seeing here
do we know what to expect next in terms
of the changes that he's going to be
making I definitely don't want to
predict the company has continued
promoting the algorithmic timeline not
as much as they were they're making it
easier for users to switch back and
forth between recommendations and tweets
just from people you follow so if I'm a
user who doesn't want to be seeing this
for you suggestions what should I be
doing to my Twitter account right you
can just choose the following selection
you can also make lists where you can
specifically choose an even more
tailored set of accounts to follow why
are musk and his team focusing at all on
updating or making changes to the for
you section
yeah I mean this makes sense for any
social media company if it's a way to
get users more engaged I mean think
about Tick Tock there for you page is
hugely popular because it offers these
personalized suggestions that get people
watching staying on the app that seems
like that would be the Hope here too
all right that's our Twitter reporter
Alexa course thanks for joining us Alexa
thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]